[Musique]
salut les gars c'est anna diarmas et je suis
ici en formation de cascadeur puis-je
obtenir des euros
je n'aime pas non plus être dérangé
[Musique]
j'accouche en ce moment donc je suis un
peu
grincheux
un peu  bit cunty
[Music]
genre de douleur un peu j'ai vraiment besoin
d'une robe ou quelque chose du genre j'ai besoin d'
une robe
pouvez-vous me donner une robe
bonjour
[Music]
étranger
[Applaudissements]
oh
êtes-vous prêt martha prêt à apprendre
aujourd'hui je
ciseaux ramen appris
[Musique]
plutôt bien pas de
sirotage
pas de jus qui coule sur votre menton
et nous pouvons utiliser vos ciseaux martha
et nos beaux ciseaux
pour que nous puissions utiliser notre usure [Musique
] puis-
je descendre
oh [
Musique]
[Musique]
dieu